Clinton Bush Trump wife brother racist
uncle-in-law after one too many the
who's who of Washington and the 1% are
running for president in 2016 but
they're not dynasties the dynasties yet
in their speeches all of them have tried
to identify with the everyday American
in her announcement speech Hillary
Clinton successfully came off more
relatable than this rice cooker
she also surprisingly railed against
CEOs and corporations sounding more like
an Occupy Wall Street activist than well
a Clinton prosperity can't be just for
CEOs and hedge fund managers democracy
can't be just for billionaires and
corporations except the ones I need to
raise 2.5 billion dollars
you're still cool it sort of proves that
Hillary Clinton is be Rachel Dolezal of
politics she's trans progressive but
it's also a big week for Bush Snoop
Dog's latest album peaches and cream Oh
oh yeah and Jeb JEB speech he kept
alluding to the mess that's been made of
the White House and the world which
sounded similar to the speech he gave
his neighbor after helping little
Georgie destroy their flowerbed the
black kid did it but mostly Jeb's
announcement was a bend over backwards
pander to the Latino community and by
Latino I mean wealthy Cuban Americans
living in Florida
beginning with and including la causa
nobley de los Estados Unidos de America
yes like all so nobly they're kicking
out other Latinos for protesting for
immigrant rights buh-bye buh-bye
bye bye wait unless you have money you
have money no okay
adios Jeb also wins for presidential
campaign kickoff most like an NBA final
game
there were bam-bams and 20 seconds of
this
and it looks like he's just running out
the clock on this one
what Bush is trying to appeal the young
folks just check out his campaign
trailer
I mean ad
Jeb Bush is just Jeb in fill me thrice
but at least he's got the support of mom
we've had enough bushes damn mama bush
but there is one candidate who defies
them all with his humility I will be the
greatest jobs president that God ever
created his sensitivity when Mexico
sends its people they're not sending
their best he's a candidate who actually
cares about people by offering them 50
bucks a pop to be part of his crowd at
the campaign launch
he's a job creator why can't Trump just
be like other billionaires when they get
bored they go golfing take their yachts
out mix meds and yet in some ways
although batched crazy Trump could be
the most honest candidate I'm really
rich at least he lays it all on the
table except when it comes to the
Lindsey Graham is running for president
nobody likes hearing about climate
change